hey guys so uh we shot a video a couple
hours ago talking about the whole
scarlett johansson suing disney we were
giving
you know our thoughts trying to see
sides to it whatever
but disney put out this response that
i'm late to discovering because i was
gone for the last few hours
and it says there is no merit whatsoever
to this filing the lawsuit is especially
sad and distressing in its callous
disregard
for the horrific and prolonged global
effects of the kova 19 pandemic
disney has fully complied with ms
johansen's contract and furthermore
the release of black widow on disney
plus with career access has
significantly enhanced her ability
to earn additional compensation on top
of the 20 million dollars she has
received to date
okay here's my thing though like all
i'll say is this
after hearing the response they don't
state
whether or not they renegotiated it
after deciding to release it on disney
plus nor
do they say if they talked with her
before making that decision
and i really do think they should have
done
both bottom line they should have either
renegotiated
or communicated with her about this at
all
like that's just plain and simple that's
it
and that's all i gotta say on that